so John this feels scary yeah it feels
like the worlds in a place that we
haven't seen for a long time people
don't just disagree in the way that
we're familiar with on the left-right
political divide there are much deeper
differences afoot what on earth is going
on and how did we get here yeah but this
is this is different there's a much more
apocalyptic sort of feeling Survey
Research by Pew Research shows that the
the degree to which we feel that the
other side is not just we don't just
dislike them we strongly dislike them
and we think that they are a threat to
the nation those numbers have gone up
and up and those are over 50% now on
both sides people are scared because it
feels like this is different than before
it's much more intense whenever I look
at any sort of puzzle any sort of social
puzzle I was just applied the three
basic principles of moral psychology and
I think they'll help us here so the
first the first thing that you have to
always keep in mind when you're thinking
about politics is that we're tribal we
evolved for tribalism one of the
simplest and greatest insights into
human social nature is the Bedouin
proverb me against my brother me and my
brother against our cousin me my brother
and cousins against the stranger and so
that that tribalism allowed us to create
large societies and to come together in
order to compete with others that
brought us out of the out of the jungle
and out of small groups but it means
that we have eternal conflict and the
question you have to look at is what
aspects of our society are making that
more bitter and what are calming them
down so that's a very dark proverb
you're saying that that's actually bakes
into most people's mental wiring at some
level oh yeah absolutely and this is
just a basic aspect of human social
cognition but we can also live together
really peacefully and we've invented all
kinds of fun ways of like playing war I
mean sports politics these are all ways
that we get to exercise this you know
this tribal nature without actually
hurting anyone so we're actually also
really good at trade and exploration and
meeting new people
so you have to see our tribalism as
something that goes up or down it's not
like we're doomed to always be fighting
each other but we will never have it
turn will never have World Peace the
size of that tribe can shrink or expand
right people that the size of what we
consider us and what we consider other
or them can can change and some people
believed that that process could
continue indefinitely but another
stirring we were indeed expanding the
sense of tribe for a while yeah and so
this is I think where we we're getting
at what's may possibly the new
left/right distinction I mean the
left/right as we've all inherited it
comes out of the you know labor versus
capital distinction and that working
class Marx but I think what we're seeing
now increasingly is a divide in all the
Western democracies between the people
who want to stop at nation the people
who are more parochial and I don't mean
that in a bad way people have a more
sense of a sense of being rooted they
care about their their town their
community and their nation and then
those who dis or anti parochial and who
you know I just whenever I get confused
I just think of the John Lennon song
imagine imagine there's no countries
nothing to kill or die for and so these
are the people who want a global they
want more global governance they don't
like nation-states they don't like
borders you see this all over Europe as
well there's a great metaphor some guy
actually named Shakespeare writing ten
years ago in Britain said he I think
it's him he had a metaphor
are we drawbridge uppers or drawbridge
Downers and Britain is divided 52-48 on
that point and America is divided on
that point - hmm and so those of us who
grew up with the Beatles and that sort
of hippie philosophy of of dreaming of a
more connected world and it felt so
idealistic and how could anyone think
badly about that and what you're saying
is that it actually millions of people
today feel that isn't just silly it's
actually dangerous and wrong and they're
scared of it I think the big issue
especially in Europe but it's also here
is the issue of immigration and I think
this is where I think we have to look
very carefully at the social science
about diversity and immigration once
something becomes politicized once it
becomes some that the you know the left
loves and are right in it then even the
social science
can't think straight about it now
diversity is good in a lot of ways it
clearly creates more innovation the
American economy has grown enormously
from its I mean diversity in relation to
a lot of good things but what the
globalists I think don't see what they
don't want to see is that ethnic
diversity is it cuts social capital and
Trust and so there's a very important
study Barak by Robert Putnam the author
of Bowling Alone looking at social
capital databases and basically the more
people feel that they're the same the
more they trust each other the more they
can have a redistributionist welfare
state Scandinavian countries are so
wonderful because they have this legacy
of being small homogeneous countries and
that leads to a set of a progressive
welfare state a set of progressive
left-leaning values which says
drawbridge down the world is a great
place people in Syria are suffering we
must welcome them in and it's a
beautiful thing but if and I was in
Sweden this summer if the discourse in
Sweden is fairly politically correct and
they can't talk about the downsides you
end up bringing a lot of people in
that's going to cut social capital it
makes it hard to have a welfare state
and they might end up as we have in
America with a racially divided visibly
racially divided society so this is all
very uncomfortable to talk about but I
think this is the thing especially in
Europe and for us too we need to be
looking at you're saying that people of
reason people who would consider
themselves not racist but moral
upstanding people have a rationale it
says look humans are just too too
different that we're we're in danger of
overloading our sense of what humans are
capable of by mixing in people who are
too different well yes but I can make it
much more palpable palatable by saying
it's not necessarily about race it's
about culture and so there's wonderful
work by a political scientist named
Karen Stenner
who shows that when people have a sense
that we are all united we're all the
same there are many people have a
predisposition to authoritarianism those
people aren't particularly racist when
they feel as though there's not a threat
to our social and moral order but if you
prime them experimentally by thinking
we're coming apart people get more
different then they get more racist
homophobic they want to kick out the
deviance
so it's in part that you get an
authoritarian reaction the left
following sort of the the Leninist line
the John Lennon line does things that
create an authoritarian reaction and so
we're certainly seeing that in America
with you all right we're saying we saw
it and Britain we're seeing it all over
Europe um but the the more positive part
of that is that I think the the localist
or the the Nationalists are actually
right that if you emphasize our cultural
similarity it then race doesn't actually
matter very much so an assimilationist
approach to immigration removes a lot of
these problems and if you value having a
generous welfare state you've got to
emphasize that we're all the same
okay so rising immigration and fears
about that or one of the causes of the
current divide what what are other cause
is the next principle of moral
psychology is that intuitions come first
strategic reasoning second and you've
probably heard the term motivated
reasoning or confirmation bias so
there's some real interesting work on
how our high intelligence and our verbal
abilities might have evolved not to help
us find out the truth but to help us
manipulate each other defend a
reputation we're really really good at
justifying ourselves and when you bring
group interests into account so it's not
just me it's like my team versus your
team you know whereas if you're
evaluating evidence at your side is
wrong I mean you know we can't we just
can't accept that and so this is why you
can't win a political argument if you
are debating something you can't
persuade the person with reasons and
evidence because that's not the way
reasoning works and so now give us the
internet give us Google you know I heard
that Barack Obama was born in Kenya let
me Google oh my god 10 million hits look
he was so this is come as an unpleasant
surprise to other people I was social
media has often been framed by
tecnologías as this great connecting
force that would that would bring people
together and there have been some
unexpected counter effects to that
that's right and that's why I'm very
enamored of sort of yin-yang views of
human nature and left-right that each
side is right about certain things but
then it goes blind to other things and
so the left generally believes that
human nature is good bring people
together knock down the walls and all
will be well the right generally believe
social conservatives not
social conservatives generally believe
you know people are can be greedy and
sexual and selfish and we need
regulation and we need restrictions and
so yeah if you knock down all the walls
you allow people to communicate all over
the world you get a lot of porn and a
lot of racism so help us understand I
mean these principles of human nature
have you know have been with us forever
what what's changed that's this deepened
this this feeling of division yeah you
have to see like six to ten different
like threads all coming together and
I'll just list a couple of them so so in
America one of the big one where action
American Europe one of the biggest ones
is world war two there's interesting
research from Joe Henrik and others that
if your country was at war especially
when you were young then we test you 30
years later in a commons dilemma or a
prisoner's dilemma you're more
cooperative because of our tribal nature
if you're if you're but you know my
parents were teenagers during World War
two and you know they would be they
would go out looking for scraps of
aluminum to help the war effort I mean
everybody pulled together and so then
these people go on they rise up through
business and government they they take
leadership positions they're really good
at compromise and cooperation they all
retire in the not by the 90s so we're
left with baby boomers that by the end
of the 90s and their youth was spent
fighting each other within each country
in 1968 and afterwards
so the loss of the World War two
generation the greatest generation is
huge so that's one another in America is
the purification of the two parties we
used to have there used to be liberal
Republicans and conservative Democrats
so America had the mid 20th century that
was really bipartisan but because of a
variety of factors that started things
moving we now have in that by the 90s we
had purified Liberal Party and
Conservative Party and so now the people
have the party really are different and
now we really don't want our children to
marry them where's the 60s that didn't
matter very much so in the purification
the parties a third is the Internet and
as I said it's just the most amazing
stimulant for post hoc reasoning and
demonization
I mean the tone of
what's happening on the internet now is
quite troubling you know I was I just
did a quick search on Twitter about the
election and sort of two tweets next to
each other one against a picture of a
sort of sort of racist graffiti this is
disgusting ugliness in this country
brought to us by hashtag Trump and then
the next one is crooked Hillary
dedication page disgusting so this this
ideal disgust is troubling to me because
you can have an argument or a
disagreement about something and get
angry at someone disgust I've heard you
say take things to a much deeper level
no that's right
disgust is different I mean anger you
know I have kids they fight ten times a
day and they love each other thirty
times a day I mean you just go back and
forth and you know you get angry you're
not angry you're angry you're not angry
but disgust is different disgust paints
the person as be it subhuman monstrous
deform morally deformed disgust is it is
a like an indelible ink there's research
from John Gottman on in marital therapy
if if you look at the faces if the one
of the couple shows disgust or contempt
that's that's a predictor that they're
going to get divorced same where as
official anger that actually doesn't
predict anything because if you deal
with anger well it actually is good so
this election is different and I mean
Donald Trump personally you know he uses
the word discussed a lot he's very germ
sensitive so disgust does matter a lot
more for him and he's that is something
unique to him but as as we demonize each
other more and this again as the the
sort of Manichean worldview that the
idea that the world's a battle between
good and evil as this has been ramping
up we're more likely not just to say
they're wrong or I don't like them but
we say they're they're evil their
satanic they're just they're disgusting
they're revolting and then we want
nothing to do with them and that's why I
think we see it when percent for example
on campus never seeing more the urge to
keep people off campus silenced them
keep them away and I'm afraid that this
whole generation of young people if
their introduction to to politics
involves a lot of disgust they're not
going to want to be involved in politics
as they as they get older
so how do we deal with that like
discussed how do you how do you diffuse
discussed you can't do it with the
reasons I you know I think you know if
something I studied discussed for many
years and I think about emotions a lot
and I think that the opposite of disgust
is is actually love love is all about
like you know disgust is closing off
borders love is about dissolving walls
and so personal relationships I think
are probably the most powerful means we
have you can be disgusted by a group of
people but then you meet a particular
person and you Jemma discover that
they're lovely and then gradually that
chips away or changes your your category
as well the tragedy is that Americans
used to be much more mixed up in their
towns by left-right or politics and now
that it's become this great moral divide
there's a lot of evidence that we're
moving to be near people who are like us
politically it's harder to find somebody
who's on the other side so they're over
there they're far away it's hardly good
to know them what would you say to
someone will say to Americans people
generally about but what should we
understand about each other that might
help us rethink for a minute this this
sort of disgust instinct
yes a really important thing to keep in
mind there's just there's research by a
political scientist Alan bream oh it's
showing that American democracy is
increasingly governed by what's called
negative partisanship that means what
you think like okay there's a candidate
you like the candidate you vote for the
candidate but with the rise of negative
advertising and social media and all
sorts of other trends increasing the way
elections are done is that each side
tries to make the other side so horrible
so awful that you'll vote for my guy by
default and so as we more and more vote
against the other side and not for our
side you have to keep in mind that so if
people on our people are on the Left
they think well you know I I used to
think that Republicans were bad but now
Donald Trump proves it and I can now
every
Republican I can paint with all the
things that I think about Trump and
that's not necessarily true I mean
they're generally not very happy with
their candid I mean neither so this is
the most negative partisanship election
in certainly in American history so yeah
four have to first separate your
feelings about the candidate from your
feelings about the people who are given
a choice and and then you have to
realize that because we all live in a
separate moral world I mean the metaphor
I use in the book is we're all trapped
in the matrix or each moral communities
and matrix a consensual hallucination
and so if you're within the blue matrix
everything is completely compelling that
the other side are there troglodytes
they're racists they're the worst people
in the world and all you have all the
facts to back that up but somebody in
the next house from yours is living in a
different moral matrix they live in a
different video game and they see a
completely different set of facts and
each one sees different threats to the
country and what I found from being in
the middle and from trying to understand
both sides is both sides are right there
are a lot of threats to this country and
each side is constitutionally incapable
of seeing them all so are you almost
saying that that we almost need a new
type of empathy
I mean empathy is traditionally framed
as oh I feel your pain you know I can
put myself in your shoes and we feel you
know we apply it to the poor the needy
the suffering we don't usually apply it
to people who we feel as other or were
disgusted by we ever I mean what would
what would it look like to build that
type of of empathy Yeah right so I think
where empathy is a very very hot topic
in psychology and it's a very popular
word on the left in particular empathy
is a good thing and empathy for the
preferred classes of victims so it's
important to empathize with the groups
that we on the Left think are so
important that's easy to do because you
get points for that but empathy really
should get you points if you do it when
it's hard to do and I think you know we
had a long you know a 50-year period of
dealing with our race problems and and
legal discrimination and that was our
top priority for a long time and it
still is important but I think this year
I'm hoping it will make people see
that we have an existential threat on
our hands our our devour left-right
divide I believe is by far the most
important divide we face we still have
issues about race and gender and LGBT
but this is the urgent need of the next
50 years and you know things aren't
going to get better on their own so
we're going to need to do a lot of
institutional reforms that we could talk
about that but that's like a whole long
you know wonky conversation but I think
it starts with people realizing that
this is a turning point and yes we need
a new kind of empathy we need to realize
this is what our country needs and this
is what you need if you don't want to
spend you raise your hand if you want to
spend the next four years as angry and
worried as you've been for the last year
raise your hand right so you know if you
want to escape from this you know read
Buddha read Jesus read Marcus Aurelius I
mean they have all kinds of great advice
for how to sort of you know drop the
fear reframe things stop seeing other
people as your enemy so there's a lot of
guidance in ancient wisdom for this kind
of empathy here's my last question
personally what can people do to help
heal yeah it's very hard to just decide
to overcome your deepest prejudices and
there's research showing that an T you
know political prejudices are deeper and
stronger than race prejudices in the
country now so I think you have to make
an effort that's that's the main thing
make an effort to actually meet somebody
everybody has a cousin the
brother-in-law somebody who's on the
other side so after this election like
wait a week or two because it's probably
going to feel awful for one of you
but wait a couple weeks and then reach
out and and say that you want to talk
and before you do it Reed Dale Carnegie
how to win friends and influence people
seriously I'm totally serious
you'll learn techniques if you start by
acknowledging if you start by saying you
know we don't agree on a lot but one
thing I really respect about you Uncle
Bob or about you conservatives whatever
it is is you know you can find something
if you start with some appreciation it's
it's like magic and this is one of the
main things I've learned that I take
into my human relationships I still make
lots of stupid mistakes but I'm
incredibly good at apologizing now and
at acknowledging what somebody was right
about and if you do that then the
conversation goes really well and it's
actually really fun
Jonah's absolutely fascinating speaking
with you it really does feel like the
ground that we're on is is a ground
populated by deep questions of morality
and human nature
your wisdom couldn't be more relevant
thank you so much for sharing this time
with this